that's actually that's that's Iceland
that's that's cold that was called
doesn't look like it but it was it was
cold no you do the very relaxed but but
pretty you were wearing we were get
through anything yeah you know cuz I was
out there for a while so they have like
a very thin wetsuit that she put on see
don't freeze to death okay yes yeah this
was actually when I was they had a nice
crane shot they went out there in front
of me and I was walking out but you know
if you have a wetsuit on the air gets
kind of trapped in there and you just
walking out and the bubbles start coming
up and right when it gets to the level
where it's had all these bubbles come
out and I'm like I started giggling
because because
go up - and then I open it up - let the
air out and then all the cold one in not
to dwell on this picture too much but
some of these hedges are real so yeah it
was Zack had the idea he wanted to put
my tattoos of my family like my family
crest and he wanted to put it everywhere
okay so these are just what they yeah
well they're they're like stickers it
takes quite a bit I mean it's about an
hour and a half makeup and the morning
just to put them all on but there's like
20 hard pieces that they'd have to put
on and it takes about it takes a long
time to get them off it was the same in
sense and sense of the setup so there's
an you've already finished the
standalone actual cigar is finished
Aquaman yeah Wow Australia that's it
here you all are celebrating your
birthday so this is your family I mean
not all of them just I think the one to
the front to your family yes is it a
ranch or yeah we got five acres five six
acres up and not in that and in
California and our animals and yeah nice
we it's kinda nice if they're too
because there's no service so we don't
have fortunately I have a lot of TV so
they don't get to see much but they just
they got to see the movie lately which
was phenomenal cuz i I've never been
able to show my kid they never even seen
Wizard of Oz so I was a little worried
like coming into it show them Justice
League and but it was amazing because my
kids can't watch anything that I'm in I
mean my grandmother came watching
anybody
like don't watch that one you don't want
to skip that one eventually I'll be able
to do something you can watch and it was
really amazing to be able to watch so at
least they could if they wanted to I
mean they might want to but mine don't
even want to watch me tell you now
watching dinotrux I said no daddy's for
the Pirates cartoon you get funny or
nicer than that I shove it in the DVD
and there's tears and tension to
dinotrux in a bit
[Music]